let's say we have the function f of x
which is equal to cosine of x
to the third power which we could also
write like this cosine of x
to the third power and we are interested
in figuring out what f prime of x is
going to be equal to so we want to
figure out f prime of x
and as we will see the chain rule is
going to be very useful here and what
i'm going to do is i'm going to first
just apply the chain rule and then maybe
dig into a little bit to to make sure we
draw the connection between what we're
doing here and then what you might see
in maybe some of your calculus textbooks
that explain the chain rule
so if we have a function that is defined
as essentially a composite function
notice this this expression right here
we are taking something to the third
power it isn't just an x that we're
taking to the third power we are taking
a cosine of x to the third power so
we're taking a function you could view
it this way we're taking the function
cosine of x and then we're inputting it
into another function that takes it to
the third power so let me put it this
way if you viewed
if you say look we could take an x
we put it into one function
that is
that first function is cosine of x
so first we evaluate
the cosine
and so that's going to produce cosine of
x
cosine of x and then we're going to
input it into a function that just takes
things to the third power
so it just takes things to the third
power and so what are you going to end
up with
well you're going to end up with what
are you taking to the third power you're
taking cosine of x
cosine
of x to the third power this this is a
composite function you could view this
you could view this as the function
let's call this blue one the function v
and let's call this the function
u
and so if we're taking x and into u this
is u of x
and then if we're taking u of x into the
input or as the input into the function
v then this output right over here this
is going to be
v
of
well what was inputted v of u of x
v of
u of x or another way of writing it i'm
going to write it multiple ways that's
the same thing as v of cosine of x
v of cosine of x
and so v whatever you input into it it
just takes it to the third power if you
were to write v of x it would be x to
the third power
so the chain rule tells us or the chain
rule is what our brain should say hey
it's it becomes applicable if we're
going to take the derivative of a
function that can be expressed as a
composite function like this so just to
be clear we can write f of x
f of x
is equal to v of u of x i know i'm
essentially saying the same thing
over and over again but i'm saying in
slightly different ways because the
first time you learn this it can be a
little bit hard to to grok or really
deeply understand
so i'm going to try to write it in
different ways
and the chain rule tells us that if you
have a situation like this then the
derivative
f prime of x and this is something that
you will see in your textbooks well this
is going to be the derivative of this
whole thing with respect to u of x so we
could write that as v prime
of u of x
v prime of u of x
times
the derivative of u with respect to x
times u prime
of x
this right over here this is one
expression of the chain rule
and so how do we evaluate it in this
case
let me color code it in a similar way so
the v function this outer thing that
just takes things to the third power
i'll put in blue so f prime of x
another way of expressing it and i'll
use it with more of the differential
notation you could view this as the
derivative of
well i'll write it a couple of different
ways you could view it as the derivative
of
v
the derivative
of v
with respect to u
i want to get the colors right the
derivative of v
with respect to u
that's what this thing is right over
here
times
the derivative of u with respect to
x
so times the derivative of u
with respect to x and just to make clear
so you're familiar with the different
notations you'll see in different
textbooks
this
is this right over here just using
different notations and this
is this right over here so let's
actually evaluate these things you're
probably tired of just talking in the
abstract
so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to and i'm
going to write it out again this is the
derivative
instead of just writing v and u i'm
going to write it
let me write it this way this is going
to be
i keep wanting using the wrong colors
this is going to be the derivative of
i'm going to leave some space
times the derivative of something else
with respect to something else
so we're going to first take the
derivative of v well v is
cosine of x to the third power
cosine of x we're going to take the
derivative of that with respect to u
which is just cosine
of x and we're going to multiply that
times the derivative of u which is
cosine of x with respect to x
with respect to x
so
this one
we have good we've we've seen this
before we know that the derivative with
respect to x
of
cosine of x
cosine let me use it in that same color
the derivative of cosine of x well
that's equal to negative sine of x so
this one right over here that is
negative sine of x you might be more
familiar with seeing the derivative
operator this way but in theory you
won't see this as often but this helps
my brain really grok what we're doing
we're taking the derivative of cosine of
x with respect to x well that's going to
be negative sine of x well what about
taking the derivative of cosine of x to
the third power with respect to cosine
of x what does this thing over here mean
well if i was taking the derivative if i
was taking the derivative
of
let me write it this way if i was taking
the derivative of
x to the third power
x to the third power with respect to
x if it was like that well this is just
going to be
and let me put some brackets here to
make it a little bit clearer if i'm
taking the derivative
of that
that is going to be
that is going to be we bring the
exponent out front it's going to be 3
three
times x
three times x to the second power
three times x to the
second power so the general notion here
is
if i'm taking the derivative of
something whatever this something
happens to be let me just in a new color
it could be i'm doing the derivative of
orange circle to the third power with
respect to orange circle well that's
just going to be three times orange or
yellow circle let me make it an actual
orange circle so the derivative of
orange circle to the third power with
respect to orange circle
that's going to be three times the
orange circle squared so if i'm taking
the derivative of cosine of x to the
third power with respect to cosine of x
well that's just going to be
this is just going to be
3
times cosine of x
cosine of x to the second power
to
the second power notice we're just one
way to think about i'm taking the
derivative of this outside function with
respect to the inside so i would do the
same thing as taking the derivative of x
to the third power but instead of an x i
have a cosine of x so instead of it
being 3 x squared it is 3 cosine of x
squared and then the chain rule says if
we want to finally get the derivative
with respect to x we then take the
derivative of cosine of x with respect
to x
now that's a big mouthful but we are at
the home stretch we've we've then we've
now figured out the derivative it's
going to be this times this so let's see
that's going to be negative 3
negative 3
times sine of x
times
times cosine squared of x and i know
that was kind of a long way of saying it
i'm trying to explain the chain rule at
the same time but once you get the hang
of it you're just going to say all right
well let me take the derivative of the
the outside of something to the third
power with respect to the inside let me
just treat that cosine of x like as if
it was an x well that's going to be if i
did that that's going to be 3 cosine
squared of x so that's that part and
that part and then let me take the
derivative of the inside with respect to
x well that is negative sine of x